- You both worked with
Sheryl Lee Ralph, right?
- Who I adore.
- Yeah.
- The great, the great Sheryl Lee Ralph.
- [Rosie] She is something else.
- [Tyler] Yes.
- [Rosie] And I got to see her
in Dream Girls on Broadway.
- You did?
- Oh gosh.
- I did more than once
because that was the best show
I've ever seen in my life.
- Oh, I love that feeling.
- And then she was the, we were
in The Flintstones together,
she ran the adoption agency
that got me Bamm-Bamm.
So we've been friends for
a long time and I love her.
I'm so happy she's
getting her rewards now.
- [Tyler] Oh, so am I, so am I.
- Yeah, you have the same experience.
What does she, what does she mean to you?
- So Sheryl and I actually
go back pretty far.
My baby brother, also a child actor,
did a show with her called
Instant Mom for four Years.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I met Sheryl, I
think back in like 2014
or something like that.
And she was just so great
with him, teaching him how to
you know, cut his teeth
in the multicam world.
And she was just one of those people
who was a constant in
my life at one point.
So to now do a show with her
and to watch everyone
realize the magnitude
of who she is and watch her
get her flowers in that way,
it's been a long time coming for me.
I'm so happy that I could
even be a part of that.